hi guys today I'm gonna be talking to
you about my weekend with raspberry pie
so as you all know from a previous video
I was selected as one of the creative
technologists for Mazda pie which still
absolutely blows my mind I still am
quite unsure how I managed to get it but
I am so so happy that I did I was lucky
enough to spend the weekend with them in
Cambridge at their headquarters and it
was one of the most inspirational
weekend's but I have probably ever had I
know that sounds so cheesy but it's so
true it was just amazing who introduced
that everyone at browse of pie or not
everyone a lot of people and some people
from other companies such as hella Karen
Lewis each of everything Pyrrha Rhoni
and everyone was just awesome they still
have a twinkle in their eye that just
showed you that they're really
passionate about what they do now to
start off the weekend we had to make
presentations about ourselves and I was
absolutely terrified but once we're
giving the presentations we had the
lovely animator of razzing I draw some
pictures of us and this was my picture I
thought oh that's pretty cool now for my
presentation I thought it went well
until I was kind of talking to people
afterwards and I realized I might have
made a mistake
I think everyone when you said Pollux in
your presentation because so it's just
like no I'm not
which bothers for that I accidentally
swore I didn't mean to it's fine though
because they didn't care I don't think I
hope not as for the Razzie pie itself
it's all in here we've got a brilliant
brilliant kid and obviously we've got
three t-shirts as well it's surprisingly
not all that hard
they've got so much documentation on
their website and they have raspberry
jams all over the country so come on get
involved as we have the creative
technologists they were so creative and
so intelligent the Minecraft stuff
special thing about it is it's got a
coat an interface behind it it's
hackable festival absolutely wacky and
crazy in the best very possible thanks
for my footage you're welcome
I got to meet some really wonderful
people short ones chickens and rocks not
you know this remarkable use the reverse
psychology a plat so let's see me play
with the pie shall we come on look at
what I'm doing so I have my raspberry
pie here we have our bread boards and
our racket board as well it's a tiny
little button and once I press this
button
hopefully form as well this which is the
camera should take a selfie of me so
shall we see if this is going to work
just so you know I have coped this all
in - but this is actually what they
taught us on the weekend you ready for
this it's gonna change
Oh oh my god what just happened that
it's previewing the camera now
and it's working how cool is that do you
want to see yourself you you're a tripod
there's a mirror behind my tripod yeah I
look at myself the whole time I'm so
great what is this is turning into an
awful tutorial let's see if this works
I'm gonna pick the button I thought I'd
just throw you in on the amazing things
that it's happening to me and my
newfound love for the Raspberry Pi
please let me know how involved you
don't be is this is going to be a
year-long thing and of course I'd like
to take you all along with me don't
forget I only got this opportunity
because of you guys and how much
motivation you'd give me to carry on and
to believe in myself and I just want you
guys to feel exactly the same believing
yourself take chances if we season
in crazy go out there and try out for it
because you never know what's going to
happen
have a lovely day or evening I my life
is kind of growing in new directions but
that doesn't mean that I'm not gonna be
uploading new videos do not worry about
that in fact my goal is actually to make
more what I can tell you though I have
been picked to be a creative
technologist for rad Supai which is
amazing